- Welcome back y'all.
I love finding great stories
from social media and
sharing them right here.
This is "What I'm liking".
(upbeat fun music)
(audience clap)
Firefighters put their lives
on the line all the time
but in Illinois, a group of
firefighters go a step further.
It's called "Project Fire Buddies",
and the firefighter led
organization help sick children
with special visits and resources.
They organize toy
drives, sponsor families.
They've even actually
arranged get well videos
from celebrities like Dwayne
Johnson and Jack Black.
So cool.
Kurt DeGroot of the "Oak
Forest Fire Department"
founded the organization and
he watches on "NBC 5 Chicago".
He's joining us now.
Everybody say hi to Kurt.
What's up, Kurt?
(audience clapping)
- Hey, Kelly.
It it's an absolute honor to
to be out here and to meet you.
Thank you so much.
- Oh man. It's an honor to have you.
First of all, thank you for your service
as a firefighter, first and foremost.
And also thank you for
taking it a step further
and caring so much about these people.
So this is amazing.
Where did you get this idea?
- So, I've been a firefighter
paramedic for 21 years now
and some of the toughest
calls that we go on is
for children, especially
children that are critically ill.
So it's especially hard because these kids
when when we go there,
they're excited to see us
but you can see the pain that they're in
and the struggle that
they're going through.
There was one child in
particular that, I mean
we would go there, transport
'em several different times
and I remember asking the family,
"Hey. is there any way we could stop by
and hang out sometime?
Maybe play some air hockey?"
We did.
It was great.
We saw how much the child loved it,
how much the family loved it
and words started to spread around town.
We found some more children
in the area that were critically ill.
We started to do it there
and spread all across social media.
And now I'm proud to say that we're
in 35 different departments
across several states.
- Wow. Look what you started;
that ripple effect, man.
It's not just visits though.
So what else do you provide?
- So we're firefighters,
so of course we're gonna,
we're gonna be loud, we're gonna be proud.
We line the streets up with fire vehicles.
We shut down the street,
we turn the sirens on, blare the horn.
We wanna make sure that the world stops
and knows that we're there for that child
and they're part of our crew
and they're part of our family.
You know, we've got given
tons of toys and gifts
and experiences through different
kind of sporting events;
once in a lifetime experiences.
Sometimes with the older
kids it's a little tough
'cause the firetrucks aren't
so cool for them, you know?
But, we make do, we figure it out
and that's where those
experiences really come in.
We've had a lot of help
from Dwayne the Rock Johnson
you know, Gal Gadot, Jack Black.
Robert Downey Jr's helped us, you know
and then, you know, since the start of it
we've helped over a
hundred different families
and we've raised just under $500,000.
- Wow. It's truly incredible, Kurt.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much.
You're such a brave heart
and such a cool heart
and sharing it with us.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- [Kurt] Oh, that's incredible.
- And that's not all Kurt.
Our season long partner
"Pilot Pen Makers of G2",
the go-to pen in the "Kelly Clarkson Show"
love what you're doing.
So they're giving "Project Fire
Buddies" a thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my, oh my.
Thank you so much.
This is awesome.
- Absolutely. Thank you, Kurt.
Have a good day.
Thank you tll our guests this hour.
Joshua Jackson, Christine
Cole, Kristen Kish
as well as Leanne and Kelly.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change.